Spanish dialects don't change very much.
Slang changes a lot, but Spanish is pretty standard.
It's not like Arabic, for example, where you have such a different Arabic in Morocco.
to Egypt for example.
All of the different Spanishes are completely mutually intelligible.
But in slang you get many different uh terms and words.
And car is one of these words that have different versions.
Money is another one.
You might hear dinero, which is like the standard word.
You might hear plata, which actually means silver.
Pasta, you might hear pasta, that's one, they use that in Spain.
So we had a few words for car.
Do you remember any of them?
Um machina auto?
Caro?
Carro.
Good.
Two hours.
Let's stay with carro.
How would you say the car?
El carro.
And how would you say a car?
Uncarro.
Good.
So it's a masculine word and we use el for the and un for a
What if we say the cars?
Los carros.
Good.
So the plural of el is los.
It's a little bit different.
El to los
The word for expensive is caro.
So it's like caro but with one R.
Caro.
So again it's a nice pair to feel the difference between having the single R and the double R, just as we saw in pero meaning but and pero meaning dog.
So how would you say the car is expensive?
El carro is caro.
Good.
El carro is caro good
So S we said was it is, she is, he is, or just is, or you are talking to usted, talking formally.
So if you just wanted to say it is expensive
Escara.
Good.
And what if you're talking about a feminine thing?
Escara.
And when I say feminine thing I really mean a feminine noun, if you're referring in your mind to a feminine noun because
If you in your country call cars machinas, then you're gonna say escara.
But if you call them autos
then you're gonna say escaro.
So it refers to the word more than the object, to the noun, the gender of the noun.
So s we have for is and
For they are or you guys are we know they always come together, we have son, son, s-on.
So if you want to say the cars are expensive
And we will use carro again.
So the cars are expensive.
Los carros son caro
Uh caros.
Good.
Los carros son carros.
What if you use a feminine word like maquina?
How is it gonna be?
The cars are expensive.
Good.
Las machinas son caras.
And the car is expensive using again machina.
La machina es caro.
Good.
La maquina es cara.
The word teacher in Spanish is profesor, profesor.
Profesor.
So how would you say he is a professor?
And we don't need to say A, we can just say he is Professor
Es profesor.
Good.
What if you wanted to say she is a professor?
What do you think might happen?
Es profesora?
Good.
Es profesora.
What if you wanted to say they are teachers and you mean a group of females?
Son profesoras.
Good.
So this is a noun.
Professor.
It's a word you can put the or a in front of.
Now we said that adjectives they change for gender if they end in o
If they don't they don't.
For example the global situation was La Global Situation.
Where does that global go?
Ah, la situation global.
La situation global.
So situation is feminine, but we're not saying globala.
Adjectives, these describing words that we can put is in front of, they only change if they end in o.
But nouns
They can change to feminine like profesor, profesora to differentiate.
So this is why it's important
to know what type of word we're dealing with.
We're doing this already, but we don't even realize it.
The moment we come in contact with a verb, we know exactly what to do.
We know it's a verb and we know how to manage it.
We don't start trying to make a verb masculine or feminine, for example.
So we're already making this differentiation, but we want to do it more consciously to get more control.
So this is a noun
Doctor, what do you think that means?
Doctor.
Good.
Is it a noun?
Is it an adjective?
Is it a verb?
What is it?
Noun.
So how do you think feminine a female doctor would be?
Doctora?
Good.
Doctora.
We just stick an A.
Good.
So how would you say he is a doctor?
S Doctor.
Good.
She is a doctor
As doctor.
Good.
Now if you want to get the plural of professor, professor, or doctor, doctor, or any other word
in Spanish that ends in a consonant, you don't add s, you add es.
So how do you think it would sound the plural of profesor
Professores.
Good.
So this is the plural for masculine or for mixed.
The plural for feminine
Profesores.
Good.
So how would you say they are professors?
And you mean a masculine or mixed group?
Son profesores.
Good.
And if they were all female?
Son professoras.
Good.
They are doctors mixed or masculine?
Son doctores.
Good.
What if they were females?
Son doctoras.
Good.
Words ending I V E in English
I V E tend to become Ivo IVO for masculine singular.
This is the one we always start from now and build from this masculine singular or neutral, let's say
So for example addictive becomes addictivo.
Now when I say neuta, we don't really have a neuta in Spanish.
We have masculine and feminine.
But the concept of neuta exists.
Let's say for example if I say it's addictive
And I'm referring to living in the mountains is addictive.
Eating healthily is addictive.
Or something like this.
Then I use the masculine singular.
So how would you say it's addictive?
Es adictivo.
Good.
How would you say he is positive?
Es positivo.
Good, and you pronounce an S where most English speakers will probably find themselves
pronouncing a Z there because in English we have positive positive so that would probably transfer into Spanish to positivo and we want to be careful not to do that.
Positivo with a S positivo
She is positive?
Is positiva.
Good.
They are positive.
Son positivos.
Good.
They are intuitive.
Son intuitivos.
Good.
What if you meant women?
Intuitivas.
Good.
Son intuitivas.
She is very attractive.
The word for very is mui and it's spelt M-U-Y.
The Y you can imagine it like an I, MUI.
MUI.
Good.
So she is very attractive.
Es muy attractivo.
Oh attractiva.
Attractiva.
Es muy attractiva.
Good
atractiva is uh showing us that it refers to a female so this would probably help us work out who we're talking about but maybe we would want to say it to clarify or to emphasize or to contrast
So how would you say that using the word for she?
She is very attractive.
I always get confused on that.
If it's el or if it's uh la or ella.
So I want you to spend some time to think about it and not guess.
Think about which is which and make a decision
Her is la.
Good.
Ella is muy attractiva.
How do you say she is very creative?
Ella es muy creativa, but she's aggressive.
Pero es
Is it agresiva?
I was thinking of the double G.
Does it stay Ah well these random double letters that we don't need in English really, they just become single letters in Spanish.
So I think there's a double S there as well in English.
Well that would also become singular.
The only double letters that cross over are the Rs and the N's.
Like connotacion.
And double Ns is.
Connotacion.
If you get a double F, double S, double G, these random double letters you get in English, they don't cross over into Spanish.
How would you say they are aggressive talking about a masculine or a mixed group?
Son agresivos.
Good.
And what if you wanted to use the word for they?
Ellos son agresivos.
Good.
How would you say he is negative?
Es negativo.
Good.
And if you use the word for he?
El is negativo.
Good.
He's very negative.
Es muy negativo.
How would you say it's intensive?
It's intensive.
intensivo.
Good.
So we we use the neuter there.
We don't know what we're talking about.
So we can just use the masculine singular which is also like neutr.
S intensivo.
How would you say they are natives?
They are natives.
Son nativos.
Good.
And what if it was a female group?
Son nativas.
Very good.